[Music]
[Music]
imagine the day when we finally overcome
the Cova 19 crisis we've rolled out a
vaccine to contain the virus and
everyone is able to go outside again
and return to their normal lives but
then we find out just as we've been
reuniting with all our old friends and
returning to work that there's another
strain of kovat 19 that's been lurking
around and it's one we aren't prepared
for could this lead to a second wave of
the pandemic would our original vaccine
have any effect on it and could a new
strain be even deadlier than the
original this is what if and here's what
would happen if the Cova 19 virus
mutated when most people hear the words
mutate or mutation they generally think
of things like special powers or
instability they're both attributes that
we wouldn't want this virus to gain but
the truth is that viruses mutate all the
time and it doesn't always mean that
they're going to cause new deadlier
symptoms what it does mean is that we
may need to make changes to how we test
for and treat the virus and to
understand why we need those changes we
have to learn a little bit more about
how a virus works in simple terms a
virus is something that can infect us
and it can be found in bacteria plants
and animals we don't know for sure
whether a virus is alive or not but we
do know that they can only multiply in a
host such as the human body the co fit
19 virus is made of something called
ribonucleic acid or
RNA for short RNA is one of the building
blocks of life and it carries the codes
that determine the order of amino acid
sequences in proteins a viral mutation
happens when the order of the amino
acids in the virus changes when a virus
grows and spreads to different people it
makes copies of its genetic code and
this is where mutations can occur if
viruses make mistakes when they copy
their genetic code they can't fix them
and because viruses make so many
mistakes copying their genetic code they
tend to change faster than other
organisms as more and more people are
infected a virus will continue to
replicate itself which gives it more
opportunities to mutate and in the case
of the kovat 19 virus also known as SARS
Kove - the mutation has already begun
but there's no need to panic
this doesn't mean that the virus is
going to become a deadlier even scarier
threat to humanity all viruses mutate
and for the most part the changes are so
slight that there are no noticeable
differences in the disease's
transmission or fatality rates as the
kovat 19 virus continues to mutate the
real differences we'll see are in the
ways that we test for and treat the
virus the tests that have been developed
to detect kovat 19 may have to be
changed over time so they can also
identify the mutated versions of the
virus if we can keep track of all these
mutations it will also help us to
develop drugs to fight them we might be
able to develop a vaccine to fight off
one strain of kovat 19 but what about
any new mutations
the good news is it's unlikely that the
mutations will interfere with the
effectiveness of any vaccine we develop
according to a biologist at Texas A&M
University the mutations of the kovat 19
virus are so slow and mild that they're
most likely to stay pretty similar to
its initial sequence we've seen this
happen before in viruses like the mumps
more than 45 years later the original
vaccine is still protecting us and even
if kovat 19 does become resistant to the
drugs we use to treat it we still have
options we could always develop several
drugs that treat different parts of the
virus we've done that successfully with
our treatment of the HIV AIDS virus if
that doesn't work
then maybe it's time we all move down to
underground bunkers and take this whole
social distancing thing to the next
level but that's a story for another
[Music]